it is a trip full of symbolism full of
jeopardy
but it's one francis was determined to
make
he is the first pope ever to visit iraq
descending the steps into a windy
baghdad
into a country where behind the pomp
sectarian conflict and deep division
still linger
and a place where coronavirus is just
the latest danger
the motorcade was a spectacle in itself
whisking him across the city
[Music]
and for a welcome of traditional iraqi
music and dance
that he clearly enjoyed the official
meetings were with the prime minister
and with the president and he brought
with him a core message of interfaith
dialogue
for a country and a region pulled apart
by religious polarization
only if we learn to look beyond our
differences and see each other as
members of the same human family
will we be able to begin an effective
process of rebuilding
and leave to future generations a better
more just
and more humane world
to the north in the christian town of
karakosh there is a wonderful vibe
[Music]
hard to believe this place was
controlled by isis
until just four years ago
[Music]
this was the church at the heart of the
town back in 2017
destroyed by islamic state fighters
the people who worshipped here if they
didn't manage to flee
were murdered today it has been restored
and father amra altoniaco is preparing
for the papal visit
there will be a day that the pope the
holy father will be
inside this church it really
it's the the news that
we waited for for a long time but even
in my dream i
didn't dream that
the pope he would between us outside the
church
the courtyard was used by isis as a
firing range
the end wall has been left as it was
peppered with bullet holes
over the road late into the afternoon
they rehearsed for the pope's arrival
here
over the weekend it is so refreshing to
be in iraq with such a positive mood
around and there's no question that the
pope's visit
will raise spirits but it is drawing
serious questions
about the wisdom of the timing given the
crowds that it will draw
[Music]
the vatican insists that crowds will be
distanced
and limited in size but the draw of
their holy father
is strong mark stone sky news in iraq